non era più forte delle specie che
nella più intelligente quella più
reattiva e cambiamenti questo
l'insegnamento che chad hardin ha
portato all'umanità con la sua teoria
dell'evoluzione
come specie cosiddetta o così auto
considerata dominante questo ci porta a
pensare che siamo naturalmente
predisposti al cambiamento
all'adattamento
gli altri studi studi ci dicono e
ripetono che siamo intimamente avversi
al cambiamento ma a percorsi libri ci
insegnano come promuovere come
abbracciare come proporre il cambiamento
cos'è che ci fa oscillare
continuamente dal voler far meglio a chi
stava meglio quando si stava peggio
all la musica di progresso a noi abbiamo
tanta fatto così nella politica ma sa
che mi fai affari tuoi campa cent'anni
inoltre due istinti principali in quello
di sopravvivenza è quello di
conservazioni sembrano in contrasto fra
loro su possiamo uccidere per
sopravvivere
arriviamo morire per i nostri figli
dov'è che sa la verità
io mi sono posta spesso questa domanda
sono una donna ingegnere che lavora per
una multinazionale americana nel settore
della vita al mentalità della calda
ancora casa precisione quando ha
iniziato 16 anni fa appunto venivo
spesso
mi dicevo spesso persone di mezz'età che
non avevo esperienza dati di fatto che
loro avevano sempre fatto così
non so a voi ma a me la frase abbiamo
sempre fatto così farvi dire
per gioco entrare nel castello del conte
dracula durante la notte buia e sempre è
l'anticristo del progetto del futuro
della civiltà moderna
ed io che sono sempre pronta a cambiare
ruoli da dieci regole che mette in
discussione se sono stato un po ero
definito la fisi
gestire ed accontentare pò troppo
definita
in questi sedici anni non solo negli
ultimi due le aziende si sono dovute
adattare a molteplici lei alla crisi
economica del 2009 agli su navi
giapponesi
hiver cannes islandesi alla pandemia
work alla digitalizzazione alla guerra
in ucraina alla crisi dei trasporti
chi più ne ha più ne metta
in vista adesso le aziende se fino a un
decennio fa chiedevano le proprie
risorse di essere dei proprio in polvere
sulla carta i propri organi
da qualche anno a questa parte le
aziende richiedono alle proprie risorse
di essere resilience di sapersi adattare
ad altare a quei cambiamenti che prima
sembravano eccezionali che ormai
sembrano l'ordine del giorno invece
io da persona difficile da gestire e
magicamente venga percepita come suonare
di niente
perché me la sono ascoltato un discorso
del filosofo diego fusaro che nella
presentazione di un suo libro sosteneva
per farla molto breve che la resilienza
il male dei nostri giorni
che i capitalisti la usano per
obbligarci ad adattarsi a situazioni
inevitabili ma che inevitabili non solo
se solo avessimo il coraggio di dire io
poi estremi per i gusti ma cosa in cui
possiamo digitare
chi di voi ha
ascoltato ho detto frasi del tipo fino
al resto connesso fino a tardi la sera
poi non riesco a parlare con la cina o
poi gli stati uniti ma perché hanno 12
ore di misurare
se non leggo quella mail nel weekend
brucia qualcosa ai vigili del fuoco
smart four kings e non vado se non porto
il pc in vacanza poi quando torno a
migliaia di me da leggere ma tutti
accettino
se non faccio la conference call è in
pausa pranzo poi non riesco a parlare
con tizio o caio faranno tutti il
digiuno già state
a dio
siamo arrivati all apoteosi della
reggenza no ad accettare tutto e tutti
senza limiti senza regole flessibili al
massimo mi ritengo una persona residente
si adatta alle acquisizioni
all'integrazione la digitalizzazione
allo smart working permanente gestisce
la clerici durante la pandemia di dei
trasporti la guerra in ucraina reti
resisto a portare il pc in vacanza
credito a lavorare nel weekend le tinto
a restare con lei sta fino a tarda sera
e di certo non certo la cosa pranzo
perché lavorare con me in calo di
zuccheri non è per niente piacevole
chi arriva ben farina personale cliente
da persona difficile sono resiliente
personalmente
sto diventando anche io abbiamo sempre
fatto così si stava meglio quando si
stava peggio
ok brivido
c'è di tutto
ed ho capito o sforzi ha deciso una la
colina
che adattarsi
davanti alle situazioni ineluttabili
quindi che non possono essere combattute
o cambiate non solo affidabile ma è
necessario parlato tramite personale
della specie delle aziende
parlo quando è
inevitabile o presumibilmente
inevitabile
magari deleterio
quando congiunto per me è perfettamente
sintetizzato dalla preghiera di
alcolisti anonimi che resta
concedimi la serenità di accettare le
cose che non posso cambiare il coraggio
di cambiare le cose che posso e la
saggezza per capirne la differenza
eureka a tutto lì
capire la differenza
capire la differenza tra la resilienza
che ci fa diventare migliori che ci fa
costruire un mondo migliore e
dall'esigenza che magari ci fa diventare
dei burattini e malia dell'antichità
sebbene possa non essere facile o veloce
acquisire questa saggezza di capirne la
resilienza
iniziare a porci la domanda è già essere
sulla strada giusta
dare la risposta corretta un alzatore
quindi io oggi vorrei veramente farvi
riflettere su una cosa
quando la resilienza necessaria quando
ingino
cerchiamo di capirne la differenza